hello everybody did you miss us well i
missed you welcome
to another episode of gamespot gameplay
and allow me to first apologize for
missing a couple of weeks because
i work with awful terrible people
and they refuse to come onto a podcast
and i don't think you all come to listen
to me just talk by myself for an hour
and a half so the good news is this week
i actually found people that want to
cast and i'm going to introduce you to
those people right now carolyn pettit
hello he's here i am and justin haywald
hey hey also here i would have been on i
was gone last week running marathons yay
did you did you win i won i won the
marathon i came in
in in the middle of uh my agent that's
that's not winning i didn't die
that that's that's a win that would be
but it's not winning yeah uh but yeah
we're good with that so uh thank thanks
for coming in but this is episode 70
by the way so uh i missed the 69 call
adam very disappointed yeah you did were
you not here for episode 69 i thought
you were here i was but we didn't say
yeah we didn't we didn't actually make
any 69 jokes which is kind of uh
depressing i guess because there are no
good 70 jokes
maybe
i think there are maybe some good 70
jokes out there maybe somebody in the
twitch chat can uh offer a good 70 joke
um
so indeed we are broadcasting live on
the internets
so if you are watching live on the
twitch
tv then by all means put in your
comments there join in have a little fun
with us and we'll have a little fun back
with you and if you're a terrible human
being then we'll then we'll catch you
yes
uh at least you'll fit right in at
justin's house so let's let's uh get
right going on into things and the first
thing i want to talk about um is the
thing that everybody loves talking about
because we here at gamespot are social
justice warriors
well i am well caroline i'm the only one
who made the list
there was a yeah there's an official
list of social justice warriors yeah it
was just me from gamespot i just you
know you're the only person from games i
was sad i really wanted to be on that
list i feel like i'm a very proper
social justice warrior but maybe not got
it gotta put it put in the time yeah
was another cbs oh yes fellow
well a cbs fellow yes right and uh yeah
so so anyway we're gonna put our social
justice warrior hats on for a minute and
talk about uh tomodachi life okay
because uh some some fans had come
forward and well carol why don't you
fill us in as to to what was going on so
i actually i'm not the most
knowledgeable person on this issue i on
twitter the other morning you know i
looked at twitter and people were
i saw tweets saying things like hey
nintendo
uh disallowing same-sex relationships is
not um preventing social commentary
you're not avoiding a social stance it's
you know it's firmly stating one i think
it was uh laura k dale who tweeted that
or something to that effect and
so yeah as i understand it there's uh
a game
tomodachi life if i'm pronouncing i
don't even know if i'm pronouncing it so
justin why don't you give us the correct
pronunciation
tomodachi life is a is a very quirky i
mean it's it's hard to even call it a
game but it's it's kind of a mini game
collection of things that you play in
your ds right and you it's a mix of the
sims and animal crossing there's not a
lot that you play it's mostly kind of
watching these interactions with people
that you you introduce into your 3ds and
in the form of your me's
in the original it's it's it was on the
original ds for uh in in japan of course
never came to america because it's
really weird and quirky you watch
basically your mei's dreams and in these
dream scenarios they they go and they
sing karaoke to living statues they
dance around a virtual boy and chant
weird things and one of the things that
happens is that you fall into
relationships with other me characters
in in the dreams or in the actual
actual lives of the characters i think
in the actual lives as well like you can
you form relationships with people you
can
foster
getting people together um but in the
original japanese version there was a
glitch that some people had exploited
where they were able to get uh male and
male and female female characters
together sure which nintendo
which when it was brought to their
attention like that this is coming out
in the west nintendo patched they were
like well like we didn't mean for that
to happen yeah uh we're gonna take that
out yeah and people thought that was a
feature
because you know because it seemed like
a normal thing to have in a game like
this which is so otherwise weird and
just completely crazy like why would you
why would you want to limit anything
sure when you're you have people
swimming out of the ocean to to do
marriage proposals to people exactly uh
and nintendo has basically come out and
said uh no no that was a that was a
problem that was a glitch we fixed it
we're sorry we're not going to change
this um but
we still like you
it's we're not trying to make a
statement with this is basically what
they're coming out and saying yeah
that's the game is the way that it was
made and that's where things get
problematic is you know that you can't
avoid making a statement right i mean
to to disallow this is not not making a
statement it is making a statement it is
it is saying that that
these kinds of relationships are less
acceptable than those kinds of
relationships and right before uh we
came up here i actually got a note from
nintendo which we added to the story
which i can read right here please
drinking news basically
uh nintendo wrote in an email uh we
apologize for disappointing many people
by failing to include same-sex
relationships in tomodachi life
unfortunately it is not possible for us
to change the game's design it's not
possible and such a significant
development change can't be accomplished
with a post-ship patch at nintendo
dedication has always meant going beyond
the games to promote a sense of
community and to share a spirit of fun
and joy we're committed to advancing our
long-time company values of fun and
entertainment for everyone we pledge
that if we create a next installment in
tomodachi series we will strive to
design a gameplay experience from the
ground up that is more inclusive and
better represents all players
so
they're they're not i mean basically
they're saying we're not going to change
it now but we're open to possibly doing
that if we do another game in the future
for all of you people who have raised a
ruckus it's interesting um because of
course part of the argument is that uh
we just don't say we don't have the
development resources or it would be too
much of a you know too much of a burden
on us either financially or from a human
resources perspective to actually do
this action although it's hard not to
look at the idea that of course they
patched out
um a very similar type of thing now my
understanding is actually that what you
were allowed to do is that you were
allowed to actually make male or female
characters have characteristics um and
where and where clothing that were
actually designed for the opposite for
the opposite genders so my understanding
is that was more of a like it was kind
of tricking the trick in the game fans
had fans had found a way to trick the
game as opposed to the game originally
supporting that uh which is weird
because animal crossing new leaf you
know is another game that i really enjoy
from nintendo and you're able to just
dress up your character however you want
you can have a male character and give
him a very feminine haircut and put him
in dresses yeah but there i mean there's
not the issue of relationships
relationships to contend with right but
you do have dogs and cats who fall in
love with you and it gets a little weird
thanksgiving when penguins move into
your town and they're just like
well we've all been there so our
penguins innis or audis i guess i don't
really know the answer to that they're
penises i don't know does that do they
even have those i don't know the answer
to anything maybe maybe if somebody in
the chat knows uh their their penguin
biology
or or what have you they can where did
this even come from i don't know i just
it just started with penguins and it
snowballed from there get it snowballed
from penguins see see what i did i
forgot what snowballed means in the in
the
normal culture of saying the bad thing
you'd figurative in the figure
yeah it just builds and builds and
builds like yeah it's something no no
but i know i i understand building and
building i thought there's another thing
that you see when you sail it's in
clerks it's in clerics you don't
remember that
i'm trying to remember okay i don't know
what's happening in this room now when
you snowball you sleep this is it's a
thing a snowball oh oh
damn it justin
you made me think of awful things
god
damn it nobody tried to inform me
no
no even i don't have a mind that bad
let's do a quiz yes
i want to get away from that for just a
second uh and we'll do a quiz so
call of duty is a big thing right now
one of the reasons of which is that we
know that kevin spacey is going to be
starring in it ostensibly is the villain
is that confirmed or is there just an
assumption i think it's an assumption
that kevin spacey will be playing the
villain of course he rants about
democracy in the new trailer and he he
it's a it's an interesting facsimile of
kevin spacey he looks more or less like
i mean he looks more like kevin spacey
than kevin bacon so that's that's good
and that why would he look like kevin
bacon well it wouldn't be bad if the
avatar looked like kevin bacon but then
if he didn't look like kevin spacey it
wouldn't make any sense anymore so
anyway i'm gonna shut up about this and
i'm gonna instead describe the quiz a
nice short quiz hopefully um and this is
a call of duty quiz versus kevin spacey
quiz oh so what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna read some dialogue and it's either
gonna be from a call of duty game or
it's going to be a line that kevin
spacey speaks in character in house of
cards
and so i want you to tell me and this is
uh this is i'll just go back and forth
between you two even though it's not
fair because i only have five but we'll
start with cairo yeah that means i get
to i get three chances yay
um so let's let's try this one uh for
those of us climbing to the top of the
food chain there can be no mercy there
is but one rule hunt or be haunted
that's from house of cards it is from
house of cards yes indeed
uh justin let's give this a try um the
just have turned their backs to become
deaf to your cries who then will show
them justice who will show you the
liberty they have promised that sounds
like call of duty it is call of duty
it's from call of duty ghosts spoken by
gabriel t rourke and so back over to
cairo oh there are only four i only
chose four i meant let's use five so
that's good one yeah so uh carol let's
try this one boundaries shift new
players step in but power always finds a
place to rest its head
i think that's house of cards a house of
cards that's modern warfare too oh okay
spoken by general shepard ouch yes
and going back over to justin for the
last one how about this one there's no
better way to overpower a trickle of
doubt than with a flood of naked truth
well that definitely sounds like house
of cards it is house of cards yes
so uh good job there and uh obviously
so general were you a fan of what house
of cards cards yeah uh i watched the
first season i haven't watched the
second season yet i found it quite
compelling um i was very disappointed
with the reporter in that that act like
as an actor i mean as as her role
becoming like something that was really
i and i haven't finished season one yet
i'm actually still in the middle of
season one but that she starts off as
like someone who's
wanting to to be uh to get to the bottom
of things she'll be an active force for
good and then she just becomes like
another pawn and just kind of a sex toy
yeah i mean i think maybe that's part of
what the show is trying to say is that
you know you play these
games you're kind of gonna get dirty too
you're gonna get caught up in them um
but yeah no i i understand what you mean
but it's relatable i mean writing about
video games that's how i got my job
yes
swept your way to the top yeah yeah well
not my way to the middle to the middle
right yeah
so it's it's interesting though because
i i've been i was watching some i
watched a whole stretch of episodes and
then the ver the last episode i've seen
was was a kiss that
just shocked the hell out of me that i
didn't see coming and that was how that
particular episode ended there were
there was not just one pers two people i
should say involved with the kiss and
that's why i was so surprised my
favorite moments on that show are always
when kevin spacey is like playing his uh
vita or his uh playstation or whatever
and it's like totally obvious that he
doesn't actually know how people who
play games like hold and use a
controller he's just kind of you know
miming it in some
i don't know some very phony way but and
then the obvious kind of
product placement kind of sony stuff
because it's all like you have a
playstation vita you know or whatever
they like they like take a moment to
spotlight the vida and talk about okay
yeah because otherwise why the hell
would he be playing on a veda
that really does not fit with his people
won't play that unless they're paid too
right i mean it's i'm just saying it
it's like it's all everything is
playstation or vita or whatever there's
no like mention
of xbox or nintendo or anything so it
seems obvious that there's a sony
tie in there
so could they be possibly uh next maybe
at some point there could be an xbox one
uh
mention no if there's a call of duty uh
oh but there won't that's that's gonna
be isn't xbox about to start making
content themselves
oh yeah oh yeah so i guess though like
xbox will be getting into the netflix
business like the original programming
blue stuff yeah the original stuff yeah
yeah so see people using connect
to do what to play
connect sports
on and that'll be a tv show no i mean
it'll be a cameo they did the they
actually had star wars the star wars
dancing game in uh an episode of big
bang theory
oh and there was a there was also an
episode of big bang theory that featured
age of conan which i thought was
interesting oh yeah well they were like
that was they the mmo that they were
playing yeah which was really strange
because nobody plays that that's the
immoral that you would play i'm kidding
i love age of conan against all odds but
uh i was so i was glad to see that an
underpraised game actually was getting a
little love but uh i also knew that you
know some money probably changed yeah
it's not it's not like the writers of
that show just loved age of conan it's
it's
it is well yeah i get maybe you never
know um but uh
yeah let's let's look at some other news
that happened this week um i'm i'm sort
of curious let's let's uh since we're on
nintendo why don't we talk more nintendo
i'm sort of curious because of course
now we you know we got to the end of
march and that's when a lot of companies
financial years come to a close and now
how well they did in the last financial
year is sort of trickling out from
different companies and so forth
nintendo though being one of the more
interesting
examples of that iwata's come forth and
said i feel deeply responsible for
you know for poor performance why don't
you kind of give us an idea justin of of
what's going on in nintendo and why
they're they're not so necessarily happy
about things well it's i don't think
it's any surprise that the wii u has not
been doing great they've nisendo i think
has been very open about saying uh we're
not doing well and we're sorry they
changed they they lowered expectations
for the wii u was going to sell near the
beginning of the i think the last fiscal
quarter and they've kind of put out some
projections again which do not paint the
wii u in a very good light at all
basically they're saying we've sold
well they're saying we've shipped i
think about 5 or six million consoles
and by the uh of six million and by the
end of this year they're going to ship
another three million so of course
that's not sold that just means
producing and pushing out to retailers
so they're not even expecting to to get
10 million consoles out by the end of
this by the end of 2014. yeah i actually
should put that in perspective a little
bit like the playstation 4 has sold
seven million sure or but another fact
that i find amazing is that the
mario kart game on the wii sold 30 35
million copies 35 million and and that's
like you know five times as many and
that's that's five times as many we use
as exist exactly in people's hands so
like we're about to we're you know
coming up on the release of of mario
kart 8 for the wii u it's going to sell
some systems definitely there will be
people who buy we use for this game but
it just shows you
how
how much less successful the wii u
has been than the wii but it's not all
doom and gloom the 3ds is still doing
really really well and you know and
nintendo has tons of money like in the
bank right they are very they're a very
wealthy company they they have a lot
stockpile this is it's not like this
would break them in any way in any way
like the gamecube did either like they
have plenty of room to experiment and
try new things and of course that's what
they're that's what they're going to be
doing and they talked about some of the
quality of life a new pillar and things
that they're going to be basing
development around and i think we're
going to see a lot more of that at e3 i
have no idea what this means well the
way that they described it before is
that they're going to try to leapfrog
wearable technology which doesn't make
any sense but we're gonna they said
basically we're gonna leapfrog wearable
technology and produce something that
will improve people's quality of life
and that's what their focus is for their
third pillar because the vitality sensor
really went well
it never came
we came out and did well but i
you know as a gamer what i i would
actually prefer that they had a bigger
focus on 3ds like i i hope that this is
a wake-up call that like they have to
have a console that competes with the
playstation and the xbox and apple and
google in terms of integration that you
can't have a handheld console and a and
a console that sits in your living room
and just have two completely separate
systems like that i can buy super mario
brothers 3 on my wii u and on my 3ds and
they are in no way connected and you're
going to make me pay for them twice like
you're
that's that's just completely
nonsensical and i would love a i would
love actually just a more powerful 3ds
or a more powerful handheld system that
maybe you can plug into your tv and play
virtual console games and otherwise it
just plays
games that are custom built for a
handheld experience
so i'm kind of curious though do you
think that uh
wearables is a
is is that really a thing does that does
that sound more like nintendo talk about
something that might end up being a
gimmick like the like this like the
second screen for the wii u or whatnot i
mean do you think that they're barking
up the wrong trees we thought motion
control was a gimmick with the weed
right but did it really go anywhere
after the wii in a meaningful way it
doesn't matter
i don't think
really because it was so financially
successful at the time so
it's changed the way that people
interact with games now it's changed the
way that microsoft and sony looked at
developing games that they're trying
true
i mean we still have all those very
traditional console experiences but it
definitely got them looking at how can
we change the way that you interact with
games and that's where the connect came
from that's where playstation move and i
think that really that let them know
there's a market for this and that
there's this is something we can create
something that will get a huge zeitgeist
a huge upswell of support behind if we
can find the right thing and they just
haven't found it yet yeah but that's but
that's sort of what i'm wondering though
is is you know we we saw you know the
success of the wii and then we saw
microsoft and sony make decisions based
on that success with the connect and
with the move but it strikes me as
though those technologies then really
didn't go anywhere that you know it it
started and essentially stopped you know
it in in the same generation and so i'm
wondering if if we've just reached a
point where
you know well the bigger problem is
something about uh like virtual reality
as well with this kind of technology
they're gonna be going up against google
and apple like they're they're pushing
past microsoft and sony but they're not
they don't have the resources of google
and apple they don't have that that
amount of research and clout behind them
in the marketplace when you think of
nintendo you think of oh they make fun
cool game things and that's what i would
have fun doing not they make something
that's going to improve my quality of
life and i would love for them to prove
me wrong that would be amazing and
really interesting that they if they
could make something that would make me
go i want this to be a part of my
everyday life but
i mean they don't have that track record
so far i mean why would i have a lot of
faith that that's going to happen do you
think that this is a case where nintendo
might even be considering something that
you know something that's so wildly
different that you wouldn't even
consider in the same space anymore like
you know are we talking about uh like
little pieces of hardware that have
nothing to do with your your 3ds or your
wii you know like uh like this is how
many miles i've walked and this is my
little nintendo thing and from the
rumors i've heard yes it's going to be
something that nobody is expecting um
and it's going to just come out of
nowhere and
and i think for us from from this
mainstream uh you know as a mainstream
audience the first thing we're going to
see when we look at it is you've got to
be kidding me this is stupid yeah yeah
but we're not going to again like the
week we're not the audience right no
that doesn't mean it's not going to fail
but it it means that it's definitely
something that i think would be worth
giving thought to and and seeing like
how how useful could something like this
be and it might just be no
you're being a complete idiot nintendo
please just make fun games and
we'll see yeah we will see
i mean nintendo it's not like nintendo
didn't start from a place like that
nintendo didn't start as a as a video
game company although it's been a long
long time
since since those early days and they
are gonna start introducing a kind of
skylanders type system with uh with
small
little mario and pokemon figurines which
could be huge i i feel like it's a
little bit late because skylanders and
disney infinity have been doing this for
so long but this is what people have
been wanting for a long time like i want
to physically collect all the pokemon
and play them in a game i think we we
just don't know yet enough or anything
really though about how these things
will be implemented right it's kind of
an announcement was basically we're
going to be using this technology in
some way with these figures but exactly
and across multiple games which is even
more like
what does that mean how will that work
what does it mean what will be stored on
the on the figures what will they bring
to the to the game experience we don't
know any of that yet
so yeah and i also have to wonder you
know because at this in a case with like
skylanders and we've gotten you know it
moves from generation to you know to
generation you don't have to buy new
hardware and and things like that all
the figures cross over and so forth the
same is true of disney infinity um where
the new disney infinity is still going
to support all of the old stuff so i
guess my question then um becomes
you know how you know are people going
to want to buy new stuff if you're a
parent and you've already bought your
kid either a bunch of infinity stuff or
a bunch of skylanders stuff and i have
to imagine that most people that would
be interested in this kind of
collectible thing have already chosen a
path to go down maybe do you think that
nintendo
jumping into this will will grab people
that would not otherwise be interested
yeah absolutely and and i think if if
kit the kids want it their parents will
buy it for them you know even though
they i mean i don't know i mean when i
was growing up and i had an nes and you
know i'd kind of begged my parents for
games and i'd say well i want
contra or whatever and my mom would be
like but it's just exactly like that
other game that you have you know which
she'd already spent money on and you
know in some ways she was right that
there were similarities but you still
you know doesn't stop kids from asking
and it doesn't stop parents from
buying that stuff
and for things like with video games
there are new parents becoming parents
every day there are guys who are growing
up and and for me this this hits our
nostalgia so much more than disney and
skylanders right i mean i exactly like i
know a lot of adults who actually got
way into skylanders originally and i
feel like like the nintendo figures have
have so much appeal for so many adults
that i know that that
for
many adults who couldn't have cared less
about skylanders
will will care enough to spend some
money on these on these types of tests
and if the game is good like well right
i mean like to me this is all so
speculative at this point all this stuff
about the quality of life stuff the
figurine stuff because we don't know
anything about anything so
we're kind of
yeah
and you put him in pokemon and then you
use mario to catch pokemon and then link
comes in you have to fight him
yeah but i i mean i i hate to be the the
cynical one here but it strikes me as
though if there's any way for nintendo
to really mess it up they probably will
come up with some way to to make it seem
not quite so friendly or intuitive
and nintendo
of course still even in this same
conference with something like this that
is such a potentially cool idea it's
very exciting
also introduced a phone app which will
come out probably by the end of this
year that lets you share
your mario kart 8 racing uh videos and
uh places because that's you know people
are really clamoring for to be able to
share this stuff for a game that's not
you know nobody really wants this whole
the whole they have a whole connected
universe on the on the wii u the the
meme
right which lets you have a community
with these people which lets you share
comments and there's no way to access
that outside of your wii u so why would
you want to use that on your phone when
you could just directly share your race
times for a game that's not out yet and
it will probably come out months after
the game
oh it's this is another one of those
moments where it's like oh nintendo
yeah i mean it's like sometimes they're
so out of touch but
there are still those times where they
surprise us i mean again the wii like we
weren't really the core audience for it
and and on sites like gamespot in the
comments you know everything is like
typically with wii related stories that
the wii is not a true console or not but
but i mean nintendo knew what they were
doing with that they were actually very
savvy about that and finding
you know moms and older people to
market that too and i mean so just
because it's not
for us doesn't mean that it's not
going to be hugely they can only do that
stuff because they're out of touch you
know what i mean right well that's true
sometimes if you're out of touch you
might i don't know i mean i feel like
that like was a calculated thing where i
mean maybe they thought that they were
designing something for
hardcore gamers but
i i think they knew what they had with
the wii i think that's why they pushed
so hard to you know to bring in moms and
grandparents and people who didn't who
don't usually play games because they
knew that that was where
they could they could make a ton of
money on that console that's why they've
always made money right right i mean
not in like this
you know i mean n64 like that was
totally for younger younger people and
the core at the time yeah and the wii u
has made a problem has made a mistake in
trying to
to court so heavily those hardcore
gamers because
i mean they've they've shown that
it doesn't measure up to the to what's
on out there right now they didn't get
the third party support they expected
right and this was a console that's
basically made for us it has hd graphics
and all these these fun games coming out
from nintendo the first party things you
want to play and no it's
nobody is making games for it it's a
heart it's a hard big
platform you know big controller yeah
the controller casual players are not
going to want to use it all hardcore
gamers barely want to use this massive
thing no it feels it feels awful well
even even beyond that i mean you say
something like i mean it's a machine
meant for hardcore gamers supposedly but
it's it's still com came with you know
visuals on par with the generation that
was just leave like we were just leaving
and it came with almost no storage space
um so i mean i know people that can't
download a single
damn game for their wii u because
there's no way to store that unless you
hook up a hard drive and and then
suddenly
again it is really one of those sort of
out of touch things where it's like if
you're going for that audience i don't
think they really knew what the audience
wanted they make so there's obviously
there's so many decisions you know
making sure it leaves us all scratching
our heads with online stuff with yeah
just design of of the wii u
um
but i'm just saying like i
i i wouldn't count them out like i feel
like that oh you can never count
nintendo wow yeah yeah
and i mean and the fact of the matter is
they've still got the handheld space
completely
there's no i mean the the one thing
we're missing in in all of this wii u
talk is that there is no real
competition for nintendo in the handheld
space we love the vita we do yeah we do
here
yeah here in the office we love the vita
i know lots of people that have the vita
that loves it but i mean
in terms of sales sure there's there's
not it's not even making a dent right no
i would give up my vita in a heartbeat
for
all of the things i can do and play on
my 3ds yeah i'm the opposite i would i
would i mean especially and looking
forward to all the indie
support you know all the indie games
that are coming to the vita
i
i can't think of anything i'm excited
about coming to the 3ds but i think of
the i think of the vita mario golf and
kirby just came out now yeah i don't
know i've i've had i don't know i'm
still trying to finish bravely default
yeah
default is great
but you know there's i just feel like
there's so much indie stuff coming to
the vita that's gonna be super exciting
so partly you know that's
that's where my my heart is at i i love
how important they
the 3ds that it has a clamshell is just
automatically better that it's something
i can put in my pocket and not worry
about it sure
getting smashed
okay it's a better portable device i'm
not saying that it's not a better device
i'm saying that the library
of stuff to me is more appealing on the
vita yeah i mean the vita has got so
much going for it it's always it always
is kind of weird that um you'd think
with a huge library of things available
to people that
you know that the veto would be more
successful but there you go
um let's see another clam shell yeah i
know right
yeah make it easier to stick in my
pocket maybe you got something
um let's let's do a quiz what do you
think about a quiz do you like quizzes
um so you know this came up for for two
reasons this particular one number one
is that it's been a long time since
we've actually played the metacritic
over and under oh yeah so and i don't
think justin's ever been here to play
metacritic over and under and i don't
think benito's ever been here i don't
think we've played it since we've gone
video to tell you the truth so it was a
good time to play metacritic over and
under and the other thing is of course i
wrote a review for a role-playing game
called bound by plane
and bound by flame is is really not a
very good game at all
um but it is the kind of game that there
there are so few games like it it's it's
very much that kind of
you know troubled buggy eastern european
type of game that tries to do a lot and
doesn't really
manage and that yeah that kind of game
you know where there's something about
it that you kind of you admire yeah
because you see what it's trying to do
and you feel like it has a certain kind
of
kind of moxie a certain kind of spirit
totally but it just doesn't come
together in a way that makes it an
actually a good game and i and i said
even in the review this is the kind of
game people are going to talk about by
saying it has a lot of heart yeah and
and i do totally by that the problem is
that it's not very good um so of course
that review went up and and uh
one thing you know now that reviews are
starting to trickle in it's interesting
of course is that it's the kind of game
that has critics split you know there's
no you know there's no real critical
mass on this one you know everybody's
everywhere it's the kind of thing i like
to see i think we all like to see in
video games because it means that rather
than all moving on mass to loving
something
or hating something together you know
here's something that's splitting
opinion right and that's always fun and
so bound by flame is a game it's
not splitting that deeply you know but
uh but there's at least not a consensus
there's not a consensus that this is the
worst thing ever or anything um and
there are some people that hate it and
some people that love it and for that
gotta give it some credit for being a
game that can inspire that and so what i
decided to do is look back over say the
last year
and choose four games that have split
okay critics in in in general and that's
how we're doing the metacritic over and
under so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to read you some excerpts from
the review
that gave it the highest score according
to metacritic and then i'm going to read
some excerpts from a review of the same
game from a different outlet that gave
it the lowest score on metacritic and
you need to see if you can tell me what
game is actually being talked about
that's that's for of course people who
haven't seen this and for justin who's
never played this game before so sorry
for all that long-winded explanation so
let's start with okay so cheat code
central gave this this game a 4.5 out of
5. okay all right and i will read a few
lines from that the game rewards players
for being meticulous and thorough
explorers you'll be sucked into the
plight of every new quest giver and stay
hooked as the missions grow deeper with
each objective achieved this is 2012.
no 20 uh 2013. oh this is just the over
the last year oh so this could this is
somewhere or it could have been a couple
months ago yeah it could have been or it
would have been yesterday
okay it wasn't but it could have been
okay
and then a quote um from the review of
the same game from videogamer.com who
gave it a four out of ten okay and said
from the first moment it's a dull dreary
affair in every respect the aesthetics
are great collections of fantasy tropes
that draw solely from the most boring
areas every one of its systems has been
done better in the past repeatedly a few
exceptions serve only as bright flashes
to illuminate the desolate wasteland of
dead ambition and imagination that is
the rest of the game and with words like
that how do you even get up to a four
right
anyway there you go it is elder scrolls
that was gonna be my guess too yeah oh i
should have i should have said feel free
to like whoever just no that's right
first i'm just happy one of us got it
yay we're cooperating
i think there's often that sense that
unless a game is like completely broken
you know or like a four is about as low
as you go unless a game just really
doesn't even function at all which i i
sort of hate that perception
you know but that's that is a perception
that exists out there and that is how i
think some
outlets
uh treat yeah they review scale and i
think it you know i think everybody is
guilty of it from time to time i mean
tom will be the first one to say you
know that he kind of hates the idea that
a game that has a certain amount of
polish is always guaranteed to to get a
you know a high-ish score at least a
seven or something like that and i know
that's actually a pet peeve of tom's is
that he hates that you know this idea of
polish
um is is as important as it is
so uh but but on the other hand we've
made our beds in in certain cases and
you know over the course of years and
now of course you know we and lots of
other outlets and and authors try very
hard to make sure we pull ourselves away
from that so that you know it people
start seeing scores on an individual
basis rather than thinking of everything
as less than a seven as somehow going on
the trash heap and i think that as games
evolve the way that we talk about and
evaluate games also needs to evolve
right you can't just keep keep thinking
about and writing about games the exact
same way that you always have when you
know games are so different right like i
mean a game like kentucky route zero
that's like it's it's so wildly
unconventional i mean you can't really
approach like if you approach it as a
product like as a typical
video game
well you know okay well there's no
puzzles or you know this or that like
but it's not trying to do any of the
kinds of things that we expect a game
like that to do so you can't really
apply that kind of criteria right well
it's like the gone home conundrum as
well it gets to the point where people
are even saying well this isn't a game
at all clearly even though it actually
clearly is right um but for some reason
um it's it's if anyone wants to know why
gone home is a game there uh steve
gainer did a talk at uh at gdc
basically i forget exactly what the
title is it was something like
why why gone home is a game or you know
is gone home a game it was one something
like that and i think you can watch the
video of it now on
the internet yeah it was on youtube
yeah gdc steve gainer gone home um and
it's you know i mean i think his
arguments for why that game is a game
are
uh
are
very in very interesting what if we gave
all games thumbs up a thumbs down
that's it i mean i there are definitely
times where i hate even slapping a score
on a game i mean i feel like again like
like again like a game i can talk about
zero is so different like in giving that
game a nine
that nine means something so different
from what it means when you give a game
like
uh i don't know gears of war three a
nine or whatever right uh so
it's weird like there are times when i
have this fantasy of just let the text
speak for itself and let's not even use
a scoring system at all anymore
it does seem like such a fantasy though
right oh yeah i mean that's not ever i
mean i i roger ebert as a movie critic
used to
talk about how he hated
assigning you know star ratings to films
but he had to because
i guess you know his newspaper or
whatever kind of demanded it and it's
readers like having that stuff to latch
on to and talk about oh this movie got
three and a half stars versus this one
got four stars and you know people love
scores and i mean i understand that i i
find them fun too to discuss and talk
about the marketing folks so they can
put on the box yeah nine out of ten well
but it's also you know in a certain case
for our readers i mean
at this stage there are i mean there are
publications that don't attach
numbers to their reviews but they are
relatively
i mean
niche publications all things considered
um you know something like rock paper
shotgun is is they're awesome but they
also don't have the same kind of
readership that a place like ign has and
honestly i actually i think there's
value in scores as long as you as long
as there's a real true understanding and
relationship between publication and
reader and i think sometimes that's hard
to establish
in part because there is no there's no
universal criteria for what especially
when you use a one to ten scale what
those things mean i actually think star
scales are a little bit easier
to handle but i think the numbers one
through ten are so wrought with
um ideas that we you know learn as kids
about uh you know zero percent through
100 and how we get graded in school and
that six is a d
you know or whatever and that's where to
me that's where this this entire idea
comes from um we've learned that you
know anything say less than you know 60
is just a failure so our minds lump all
of those things
into that criteria and it's done deal
and it's not just readers i do think
that it is authors as well who did that
for so long that all we did is
contribute um to the idea that that
basically anything that's less than a
seven is is unworthy especially when
even even when i was in school like any
anything to me that was less than a b
would have been disastrous in my head so
you know for me i even grew up thinking
that anything that's less than 80 must
somehow be
you know
you know just for developers
i mean developers who can
they lose bonuses for not reaching
metacritic score
thresholds they
people lose jobs over it which is you
know what
it because attack the text of the review
itself is so deeply personal like maybe
the score itself should also become more
personal like if i wrote uh reviews on
the regular i maybe i would take
pictures of food and that would be my
score would be a picture of food
it would be an abstract thing you'd you
kind of have to confirm based on what
you know about me what you know about
yourself about what you think about that
food and that would represent the score
okay
like some scores would be a croissant
maybe some of them would be curry just
in the the world isn't ready for these
ideas yeah i i don't know about i don't
know about this i don't know if this is
getting anywhere i mean this is maybe
that's how our grandkids will read video
game reviews think about it and we can
talk about it later yeah i like it new
game spot i like it all right next next
metacritic overview oh i i forgot we
were playing our game yeah thank you
carol for keeping me on track okay let's
let's try this one so from um
from financial post from the financial
posts i love their video game reviews
yes great they gave this game a 9 out of
10.
it seems foolish to make any
proclamations about what will stand out
at the end of the year but i can't
imagine that i will soon forget my
experience it's not without a few warts
i'll admit i clearly wish that the sound
design was a match for the rest of the
game and the second to last chapter is a
bit of a slog
so that's from financial post okay
um interestingly saying i foolish to
make any proclamations about what will
stand out at the end of the year but i'm
going to make a proclamation about how
it will stand out at the end of the year
so obviously something that was earlier
in the year
possibly or this year or last year this
year or last year yeah
um from egm okay electronic gaming
monthly a 3.5 out of 10
on this one
it's rare in this day and age that we
see a heavily anticipated aggressively
advertised game shoved out the door in
such a sorry state there's a spectacle
and a failure of this scope something to
be admired and being unashamed to do
something so wildly different even when
different means bad
is it a 3ds game
um
no i'll say that it's not that
it's
it's not resident evil 6
no okay praising the sound design
no saying that we're saying the sound
design isn't up to the level of the
wrestling the good review said the sound
design wasn't quite up to where it's a
heavily advertised game it was rushed
out the door
by
youtube
um
i'll give you five seconds
to see if you can come up with something
i thought you're gonna say five hints
here at gamespot i reviewed this game
and it was in the middle between 3.5 and
nine
yeah i don't know no this would be teef
oh
oh oh okay yeah
this was uh the thief reboot rebuked the
rebuke of thief
uh so yes that was that was teef there
um let's move on to another one
um from digitally downloaded it's also
another famous site um four and a half
out of five stars
they say this the themes demand that you
experience a solitary lonely quest for
what ultimately amounts to absolution
and redemption as it is a desperate
quest and desperation has a greater
impact when it's tackled alone this
creates some very odd and fantastic
moments of story complete with awkward
delivery and while it does provide a
useful answer to the nihilistic
philosophical puzzle the narrative does
try to be a little too smart for its own
good yeah
justin over there making some some
crude motions yes
and from cheat code central uh 1.9 out
of five okay
this is fan fiction level storytelling
people
pete i love that at the end
this is fan fiction storytelling people
i like people that write like they talk
that's fun to me
um where'd it go okay it's all melodrama
and deus ex machine and i wanted to make
sure that i said it exactly as it was
written this is deus ex machine okay
it's just a quickly thrown together mess
of mechanics and frankly you aren't
missing anything if you totally pass
this title up
that didn't really describe it very much
no but i i i worry that if i describe it
too much that it just immediately gives
away what the game is deus ex
no no it's not descent
daylight
no no but good try
shooter
somebody in the chat did get it
um so we've we've got that anyway
um it is not a shooter for what it's
worth
i can't think of many shooters that
actively explores
uh nihilistic ideas like that as soon as
you start writing something like that
though you're just
that's any game you're you're just being
ridiculous
what are you talking about there are
absolutely games that deal with themes
in in very serious ways who's writing
the the way that the the
thing was constructed i i i disagree
completely i think that i mean i don't
know what game we're talking about but i
don't see anything wrong with talking
about games that way i'm gonna guess it
doesn't matter the game doesn't merit
does that kind of describe i would agree
that the game does not merit that kind
of discussion that's fair
but uh it i mean it's somebody that
obviously took to this particular story
and that's quite fine of course so um um
super mario 3d world
no i'll give you i'll give you five more
seconds to see if you can come up with
anything um let's see
coincidentally another game that i
personally reviewed
um and i obviously fell in between
because i wasn't either the one or the
one or the other although
um
yes anyway that's that
were you closer to one end or the other
um let me see let's see um
yes i was closer to cheat code central
than i was to digitally download it so i
was closer to the bottom okay oh uh
score than i was to the top scorer okay
as it were
all right the answer is final fantasy 13
lightning returns oh my god so
well but i mean that is a game that is
it is trying to do stuff thematically
that is like
you know profound you can argue that it
falls on its face but i don't think that
there's anything inherently wrong with
talking about the game as
grappling with
these kinds of no not at all and
actually before
um before the review came and a preview
um
date had come i actually wrote up about
about uh the game's religious themes and
how they they very clearly mirror
certain aspects of of christianity so
you know there's something to be said
there i don't think in general
but uh yeah um there's that so let's uh
move on to the is this the last one yeah
this is the last one
um so from gamesbeat okay all right 86
out of 100 yeah
this is a game where the characters are
almost always yelling fierce
blood-curdling battle cries
you go from one fight scene to the next
naturally this isn't a game for your
kids to play or watch when i finished
playing this game i felt like i wanted
more that's the mark of a good game oh
god i also felt like i had played
something fresh
fresh fresh is it that's
exciting is it
i want to hear the bad reviews the bad
review from metro game central yeah
three out of ten yeah with no other
substance the gameplay mechanics you
feel like you're being trained like a
circus animal responding with pavlovian
pavlovian loyalty uh pavlovian loyalty
whenever someone flashes the light color
or an enemy lunges at you is it the
right color is it rise it is rye son of
rome yes indeed
so uh
pavlovian thank you i can actually say
that
i like anyone who describes the game as
fresh kind of surprised that three is
the lowest for ryze actually yeah yeah
um
it's funny because i think that game is
is trash and yet i ended up playing
quite a bit of it you you had trash but
i ended up kind of it's weird isn't it
you have such pavlovian loyalty to it i
and we reviewed it mark gave it a four
yeah um i think that he's probably about
right on actually i might have just
called it mediocre had i ultimately like
done a second review or something like
that it's a weird game it's it's really
weird in the way that it's so bad and
yet it kept me kind of coming back it's
sort of the re and i think the reason is
and we've talked about this before is
that when it comes to my like personal
game time which i don't have a lot of
because i end up playing for work a lot
of really long games
and so for in my personal time i like
things that are short and really shallow
a lot of the time and rise is absolutely
incredibly shallow
and that's where it's a i found it its
appeal
is in how easy it was how i could sit
down not think about a damn thing
and play something that i knew was bad
but was at least put together well yeah
if that makes sense just respond to the
cues and just push the buttons that it
tells you to put it was just uh quick
time events all night long yeah yeah so
uh but it sounds terrible yeah the worst
thing
it wasn't great um but but again i
understand the appeal and i actually
shared in some of that appeal i actually
played a bunch online
but i was really pissed off because some
of the uh
because some of the uh achievements you
couldn't get unless you downloaded the
uh
the map that was for sale oh yeah and
ryan had an online
it did it did it had an online feature
like you played against other people
yeah one other person always you and one
other person but it was not against it
was cooperative
so it was basically sort of like uh a
horde mode
of sorts only with qtes
i'm not more intrigued yeah i know you
shouldn't be you shouldn't be i wouldn't
actually recommend the game to somebody
really um but i would i would absolutely
say if i don't call it mediocre yeah if
somebody told yeah it's kind of weird
like if somebody told me that they that
they that they were into it i'd say yeah
i get that
you know but it's the kind of thing
where it's like i wouldn't tell anybody
else that i that they should assume that
they too will be into it because
it's just one of those things
um so anyway somebody bringing up it's
funny girl draco and chat bringing up
kevin forgets that ninja blade was also
mostly quick time events that's not
really true i mean rise is nothing but
that um in a sense whereas ninja blade
had regular combat but it's quick time
events were also accompanied by some of
the most ridiculous
funny awesome quick time events i've
ever seen so that's that's what made
that game that game had a an attitude
um and that kind of attitude is actually
pretty where um a lot of other you know
developers try to go for that i think um
suda tries to do things like that but he
just does it with you know very overt
sexual tones whereas you know this was
just silly and very kind of
self-effacing which which i liked anyway
enough about ninja blade let's talk a
little bit about more
news
and then we'll do the our final quiz
which will be the uh the audio quiz this
week but uh i wanted to talk a little
bit about
um steam early access
and and kickstarter um in the sense that
i want to talk about some
some games that have not been pleasing
people of late now that we're seeing
we've seen kickstarter successes and now
we're starting to see early access and
kickstarter i don't know failure is the
right word but there are some
failures i guess i would say i'll start
with a gamespot news article and talk
about
earth year 2066
um one such game recently i don't know
if either one of you have been uh
had paid any attention to that this is
an eddie story so i wasn't sure i know
there was one called towns that
oh yeah we'll get to town is this a
kickstarter one this one is a a steam
early access this was um
a game that ended up being you know it's
being billed as an open world
um post-apocalyptic type deal and it was
really just a very small map where you
went out and shoot and it was really
awful and we actually reviewed it yeah i
remember now reading the review yes yeah
and it was it was clearly trash yeah um
this was a game by the way that had been
greenlit so this was a game that people
looked at said i think this is
interesting i'm going to trust this
person enough to vote them up on green
light
and that means then of course that they
will be able to sell their game on steam
and have it be available via early
access and so on and so forth and so of
course
um we all know how this is gone at this
point which is the game was pulled from
steam um valve came right out and said
that um
you know let me see if i can find it
about basically saying hey the game
crossed a line there's a difference
between being available early and just
clearly being
almost a scam
so um i think that a lot of people have
reached the conclusion that
this is somebody possibly that bit off
more than he could chew like a single
guy who decided to uh to make this thing
and clearly isn't capable of it but uh
you know sometimes the elevator pitch
you know they you know in this case it's
a guy who gave his elevator pitch and
people people fell for it and and said
yeah we'll we'll vote you up
well and you know sometimes you
you set your sights really high you're
like i want to do this and this is my
dream and i want to make this happen
and then you actually start to work on
and you're like oh yeah i suck i can't
i'm not going to live up to the
lofty ambitions that i set for myself
but i'm glad that all of you believe in
me yeah watch me fail
i'm sure he's getting a kick out of that
haha look what i did to you
um another game and and i found this on
kotaku so forgive me for uh moving
things away from gamespot every so often
but
um this is a game called uh called towns
so this was also about this on gamespot
as well i believe is it okay pretty sure
i i didn't see it on gamespot but i did
see it on kataku so my apologies but
hello to my friends at kotaku um so this
was a game that that launched in
november 2012 as a first batch of games
on green light
and originally been promised to combine
ideas from sim city dungeon keeper dwarf
fortress and even diablo
but none of those ideas were implemented
when the game actually went up for sale
so
and and now
um that they've
you know the the development hands went
over to another individual and then
ultimately he's like i can't this is i
can't do this it's over
all of it's done shut it down shut it
down even though the game is nothing
like what was promised and people of
course had had uh had backed it
and
it was released um
before early access even existed so this
is a case where a game actually came out
and you know when you bought it on steam
you this was a game that you bought it
was a finished game that was the the
implication at that stage because there
was no such thing as early access on
steam when it when it first released um
but yeah you can still pay money for
this as well yep it's still there and
it's just getting a lot of negative
reviews
yeah people are saying don't don't buy
this and florian frankenberger who was
the developer uh the remaining developer
on this project said uh
sorry it's done but then he went on to
say well maybe there will be a sequel
so
i'm gonna guess that we probably
shouldn't buy the sequel i'm gonna go
out on a limb
and say that we probably shouldn't buy
the sequel even though we don't know
anything about the sequel
just saying you might have learned from
his mistakes
maybe it might be better you never know
well at least
he'll need like a sizeable team
and then this reminds me of this the
story is a little bit older this is not
a recent story this is mostly from
january of this year
um but it reminded me of an experience
that i had so i don't know if you guys
just i don't think you were here at the
time yet but i'd reviewed a game called
akinero demon hunters which was uh
which was sort of a diablo-esque uh
top-down clicky game um coming from
spicy horse which is american mcgee's
studio and and of course a lot of people
know that i love love love american
mcgee's alice it's one of my favorite
games of all time that we're gonna see i
love love love american mcgee no i uh
well that well let me continue the story
and you you can decide
you know that and i'll i'll try to keep
it nice and brief um but i reviewed the
game i gave it a five and uh in part
because you know i ended up spending
money on that game even though it was
free to play
um i ended up spending more money than i
would have if i would have just
given twenty dollars to play something
like torchlight two
and
so because just because of the way it's
free to play was set up it was just so
money grabby that if i had any hope of
ever finishing
um i needed to i needed to pay some
money
and and so i did and then ultimately we
reviewed it i gave it a five out of ten
and that's more or less where the
metacritic landed i think the metacritic
can be only like 55 or something like
that
but he sent me an email
um in part imploring me and not
understanding why i didn't
take into account the fact that a lot of
features were going to still be coming
like i called out hey this game doesn't
have co-op but the game was going to
have co-op this game had these things
broken well these things are going to be
fixed
and it's one of those occasions of
course where a lot of people think that
we should be
you know
reviewing a game based on not just what
it is but what it might someday perhaps
potentially maybe be yeah um and i get
that sometimes there are developers that
that are respected you know if stardock
you know releases something that needs
to be fixed for example you can usually
know that that thing is going to be
fixed um but we can't
you know we can't live by that you know
on hypotheticals and babies like we have
to review
the game as it is that for you know what
at the time of review what will you get
for your twenty dollars or thirty
dollars or sixty dollars like this is
the experience that as
as i this is the game as i experienced
it right now right and i mean we've
gotten to a stage now in in games anyway
where when you buy a game you're you're
you know even when it's not early access
a lot of the time you're still buying
you know it's always the case when you
buy something right there's an element
of risk there's an element that you
might be contributing money to something
that's not going to meet your
expectation and so on and so forth but
we've reached the stage where we really
are buying promises a lot of the time
now when we when we give money to
developers we're not just buying their
product we're all buying the promise
and again almost all games come with a
day one patch now like i sure i can't
remember the last game that doesn't have
an immediate this is gonna require a
substantial patch on day one yeah
but there's but
going back to mr mr mcgee
um ultimately um spicy horse ended up
losing a lot of money even after they
because
once the game was even considered
released
they then did a kickstarter because they
needed they wanted to continue
development on it so they could add
other things and so they kick-started
and and then ultimately early this year
lots of these things just never happened
all of the things that were on the list
of promises things like uh you know
co-op and uh and and so on and so forth
just didn't happen because the that they
just siphoned money
um
and it was i think their first
experience with kickstarter that
developers first experience and you know
there's a there's a big like you know
facing reality moment where you realize
like things that happen in development
all the time in terms of how financials
don't go the way you expect or the
development process doesn't happen the
way you expect suddenly he had not just
to answer to his himself and to you know
his financial backers well he did have
to answer financial backers everybody
all of the people that had had
contributed to kickstarter so
um yeah it's just an interesting week
where i where i was thinking of like the
lessons learned about how we're giving
money to developers um specifically for
their promises and you know above and
beyond just the product that we're that
we're getting and that's one of the
reasons we do early access reviews now
is that uh you know you
you know the developer wants your money
you should at least be able to know how
good is the thing that you're getting
right now
so that's what about when you give them
money for things that aren't even gonna
necessarily be released like uh double
fine you know tim schafer and their
their team with the broken age
rpg i think i think they did a really
great job of making it very open with
what they're doing and how things are
coming along but i mean you're basically
giving the money and saying we'll help
you make a game with this
because you might not you don't have to
right well i mean i think they have a
you know that with there at least
there's some kind of history and track
record that you can look back on and it
gives you some reason to
put some faith in them that they they
know how to make games they i mean but
even there then it became this thing
where
well the original kickstarter for broken
age they made
more money than they asked for if i
recall correctly
lots more money but then because the
game grew based on the amount of more
money that they asked for then they
they had to do this thing oh well now we
you know we have to break the game up
and
right so so
even for them there were there were
these
kind of rough spots and this this last
this uncertainty about what the money
coming in means and how to develop
around that or within those constraints
right and so i think there are just
lessons being learned on all sides here
by developers by consumers i mean
whether these are whether these lessons
are being learned or whether the same
kinds of mistakes will continue being
made who knows but
i kind of wonder when we're going to get
our real first high-profile
video game kickstarter failure you know
something along the lines of it and this
isn't this isn't to uh
you know to jinx anybody but let's say
for example something on the size of
star citizen
were to
were to fail um somehow that that uh
chris roberts doesn't doesn't deliver on
what was promised or doesn't doesn't
even get close to delivering what was
promised star citizen which has made
millions and millions of dollars right
what happens then if suddenly that just
it just falls apart it falls apart
you know that and he just ends up in
mexico somehow
drinking margaritas
i mean i'm not suggesting i mean this is
one of those cases where that we we have
enough reason to believe that he's going
to do a fine job of delivering um
a game that clearly had millions of
dollars spent on it um but i kind of
wonder about when when does that moment
come
and i don't know enough about other
kickstarted projects outside of video
games to know how frequent a very very
large project does fall apart you know
outside of games it seems to happen
pretty frequently i mean we we've seen
some sony studios which you know when
they say that we're uh going back to the
drawing board and we're laying off a lot
of people that's basically saying what
they were working on was a complete
failure and we fired them
yeah
but in a very nice way
you know usually and also like internal
restructuring like when you're going
like you guys have been working on
something and we don't like it so
uh we'll we'll try to get some of you
other jobs in other parts of the company
where maybe they're working on something
that you can do but the rest of you are
just going to go back to the drawing
board and do something different because
yep this ain't working out you know
and so on that no let's go on to
something more fun which is music
um so put on your headphones this is
gonna be the music quiz i actually have
a nice pair of headphones this week
because we didn't have to
to share anything which is good and so
benito is over there he's gonna play
some music now here's here's what this
is based on so of course sunset
overdrive has you know lots of
information has suddenly come out about
sunset overdrive which is uh insomniac's
upcoming game
and it looks cool it has an interesting
art style it's gonna be an open world
um action game so what i did is i put
together and we've done an open world
action game sound quiz before but i
believe that there's only there might be
one game that crosses over but none of
the tracks are the same so why don't we
go ahead and start with the first one
and first come first serve whoever
figures it out first gets the points and
you know i'm loaded with points today
unload all your points ew
this is an open world game
this is an open world action game
because i would have thought the last of
us but
that's not open world no and it's not oh
there we go
it sounds very metroid
it's not another m is it is that open
world-ish that's
explore
no
is it gravity rush no no okay
i'm letting it go so that uh other
people can in the chat can also try to
figure it out it's
obviously it's not titanfall which is
also not open world
like this kind of sound like titanfall
though
yeah i know i get that but uh it's
nobody's nobody's getting it is it
well i mean it's not a huge game so i
didn't i didn't start with an easy one
but i'm surprised that nobody figured it
out very simple is it defiance
it's not defiance the answer is this is
crackdown two oh
yeah so yeah that's uh that's cracked
down too so obviously the um
the disappointing sequel to the original
crackdown which in and of itself had a
lot of room to grow and then so they
made it grow by making exactly the same
game
so good good job there
uh i'm sorry that was mean i shouldn't
say good job there that's that's a
little too
a little too mean even for me let's go
ahead and try the next one again this is
an open world action game
sounds a whole lot like the last one
it's a challenge to write this kind of
music though that can like play
throughout the whole mmo session forever
that's some trumpets kind of very
mariachi sounding
i feel like a rattlesnake's about to
bite me
oh jessica
no
red dead it is red dead yes this is from
red dead redemption yeah
so uh and and excellent seriously that
music just says
uh desert to me
like
seriously i'm going to be you know
bitten by a rattlesnake anymore what's
about to rattle snakes bite is that what
they do or do they just uh they'll bite
yeah they do okay yeah
i was watching qy last night actually in
there i had a discussion about snakes
but that's a day for another that's us
something for another time benito we
should move on to the next open world
action game what do you think sure all
right let's do it
sounds super firefly
you know
oh there we go
very people and armor and suits and
going to war
lord of the rings online
now it's an action game
it's an overworld action game it's
action so no mmos here no
no games i would consider role-playing
games
skyrim
people are
have the right uh kind of thing going in
the chat but they're choosing the wrong
one
so it's a game with multiple entries
this is a game with multiple entries
but people are choosing the wrong one oh
uh uncharted that's not open now
i got well i know this game
there's action
yes we've established this
so yes it is assassin's creed
the chat but the question is which is
which one is it
um and people people kept choosing the
wrong one at first this was three yes
wow i would have thought it was great
three i would have thought black flag
sounded more
it sounded more i don't know
like a little piratey rather than kind
of colonial america yeah but you have to
remember too that they were actually
going in that direction with the ship
comics sure yeah so and i think that's
what they were uh
i think that's what they were going with
but most of the ones i saw in the chat
first were assassin's creed four yeah so
i had to i had to pull them back just a
little bit
and what do we have next oh let's go for
number four and see if anybody gets this
particular tune which is just rollicking
and fun
so rollicking and fun that there it goes
here we go
my headphones keep going in and out i'm
sorry
stupid headphones
this has got a good beat i could dance
with this
bottle full of
yes can only find yes is one true love
no
with a dog
no who's able to sniff out
no her zombie brains no
zombie love the movie no
that's not what this is
this game has no zombies
dust
it might have dust
dust i know which i know what you're
talking about
who's on first
i will let's see if i can give you a
hint this is a game that came out this
year
and again it's an open world action game
so people saying beyond two souls can
can stop that
there's not a lot of games that have
come out this year it's we're limited
yeah
hi i keep expecting the music to give me
some kind of hint
oh wait is this the beginning of uh
that chris isaac song
for a moment i thought it was gonna and
i
wanna fall in love
that's what he sounds like
in that song all right so the answer is
infamous second son oh
i've not played that yet i can't believe
that didn't even occur to me for some
reason and if there's anything that says
infamous it's all of that music that
says
nothing at all it's like portland
the game is set in seattle though yeah
oh
they're the same place to me okay yeah
are they to offend our listeners who are
from one of those places not to offend
you but here's something offensive
specifically
and we got vanita we got one left so why
don't we uh throw this one in again open
world action game
by the way i i chose some of these on
purpose because they
use many of the same musical ideas
spelunky
time that means you know you're in a
rush here
the ticking clock
move you forward
girl singing
final fantasy
that's rpg
lightning returns was kinda
some very new aging
i actually really like the soundtrack
so something supernatural to all this
yes
a little bit
sneaky it's one of my favorite games
over the last couple years although it's
not one that we really talk about in the
office so it's that's not really helpful
sadly what's that sadly because i love
this game yeah yeah it's just not one
that really caught on in the editorial
land
probably not a game that i even played
then
it does not sound familiar at all
[ __ ] rocking out now
all right let's have some hints since i
want to see somebody get it before i
before i just tell you what let's let's
see all right this is part of a series
this is a game that is in a series
and in fact the original game in this
series has been getting a little bit of
attention because it was i think
re-released on steam
recently
and it is the game that
made
a particular developer's
uh
reputation
for making
these kind of beautiful games although
now that developer doesn't make this
series anymore
saints row no
the fourth although the original
developer has gone on to continue its
reputation for making
high budget
very good looking video card breaking
games
i got nothing i'm yeah i mean this music
is is beautiful i but i don't recognize
it at all let's see what else okay so
oh god the best video game villains from
that year yes it was a great video game
villain okay um who defined insanity for
us kevin spacey
what is the definition of insanity caro
uh
it's doing the same thing you've always
done expecting
nobody remembers i'm sorry really oh
gosh what else okay um
sean reviewed the second okay jason
ocampo reviewed the first game in the
series sean reviewed the second game in
the series i reviewed the third game in
this series
assassin's creed no
kingdom hearts the second game in this
series had malaria
oh oh oh uh
far cry yes this is far cry 3. okay
i really love far cry 3. it was so good
i didn't play it that year though the
year it came out so i didn't actually
vote for a game of the year i would have
though if i played it that year oh my
gosh that was sorry that took way longer
than it should have that's quite fine i
don't know why i it's late people got it
in the chat though right
it's friday afternoon
uh
you're all terrible all terrible the
chat got it though right oh yeah they
had a long time ago
but i know being on the other end
suddenly when you're on the spot how
ridiculously tough that can sometimes be
i need to play those games i'm sorry i
went too long everybody's complaining
that i let that go too long well right
now maybe we'll just sit here and uh do
nothing for a little while and we'll get
staring we'll see we'll see just how
long it goes then for you huh
anyway thank you um first of all to the
people in this room i'm gonna i'm gonna
start with benito this time so that i
don't leave him out because i've done
that before
so thank you benito for being awesome
and for running the machines he is the
most important part of this show he is
the most important part of this show
besides
justin haywald i am the least essential
part of this show you're right you're a
part of the show i am hooray the
appendix you're like the alan davies of
the show i don't know you don't know who
that is hopefully my the british
watchers and listeners know who is that
thing yes it is thing hooray i need to
watch qui you can be the illegally on
youtube you could well you could it's
not illegal on youtube it might be
illegal for them to have uploaded it but
it's not a legal fee to watch it
um and yay carolyn pettit was also here
thank you
you're welcome
and thanks to everybody out there too
you're awesome and you should number one
you should subscribe to us
on twitch because
usually we try to be on fridays at 3pm
live sometimes that doesn't really work
out as as well as i'd like it to but you
should still do it you should still
follow us on twitch you should also
follow each of us individually on
twitter cairo is carolyn michelle and
justin haywald justin heywald
and benito uh bang3beng3
and me i'm fiddle cub and also subscribe
to this very podcast on your favorite
podcast player whether that be itunes
whether that be
i know you've got a zune in your pocket
the the two of you that that have zooms
all both of you watch the show i'm
pretty sure listen in i'm kind of
downcast
yeah very totally stitcher we're on
stitcher as well and we're in we're in
other places so whatever your rss feed
player is just use that listen to us
every week or whenever it is i decide
that i'm gonna gift you with a special
podcast and so thank you for tuning in
and uh if all goes well we will see you
next week for episode 71
on game supply gameplay